totin common spectacular
[Music]
Treasures
now for the first time since they were
discovered all
5,398 objects are being brought
together in a new $1 billion
[Music]
Museum this will be the first time many
of them have been seen for a
century look at the horse look at the
horse look at the horse scientists have
been using the latest Imaging and
forensic technology to unlock long
buried
Mysteries to reveal The Man Behind the
Mask so many tiny details are visible
again this wasn't just a hall of
treasure it was a veritable
Arsenal not of a boy
King but a warrior on a global
stage Egypt's spectacular Tuten
[Music]
common he's the most famous most studied
Pharaoh in
history but even today tutan Common's
Treasures still have much to reveal
now the most comprehensive forensic
examination of all Tuten Common's 5,000
Treasures is
underway and several key objects have
captured experts
attention at the heart of the
investigation a mysterious dagger found
on Tuten Common's mummified
body Priceless golden in Chariot
decorations painstakingly reconstructed
after resting in fragments for 3 and 1
half thousand
years and the leather remains of a
strange armored
tunic these three Treasures will tell us
much more about the real Tuton common
not as a boy but as a
warrior it's a new chapter in a story
that began in the Valley of the Kings on
the afternoon of November May 6th
1922 in the barren desert west of the
Nile British archaeologist Howard Carter
made the greatest archaeological
discovery of all
time the almost completely intact tomb
of an ancient Egyptian
pharaoh tutan common
egyptologist Dr Chris nonon has been
given a rare chance to get up close to
Howard Carter's personal account of the
momentous
Discovery this is Howard Carter's
journal and it's amazing for me to see
this because this it really is as close
as you can get to the very moment that
Carter looked on this incredible Hall of
objects for the very first
time this meticulously handr written
entry records Carter's astonishment as
he peered inside the tomb becoming the
first person to Gaze on its wonders for
3 and a half thousand
years says the interior of the chamber
gradually loomed before one with its
strange and wonderful medley of
extraordinary and beautiful objects
heaped upon one another when lord
canavan said to me can you see anything
I replied to him yes it is wonderful
tutan Common's Treasures captivated the
world in the months and years following
their Discovery they were painstakingly
excavated and transferred to the Cairo
Museum since then millions of visitors
have marveled that many of the items
found in tutin Common's
tomb these iconic Treasures paint a
picture of a Pampered boy King who died
tragically
young this is the Tuten common every
school child
knows a boy too young to rule an
emotionally and physically weak puppet
ruler but this image is based on the
tiny handful of Tuten Common's Treasures
on display in the Cairo Museum that make
up just a fraction of the 5,000 objects
found in Tuton common burial
[Applause]
chamber the rest have been locked away
in the Museum's
basement until
now the new Grand Egyptian museum is now
gathering together all of Tuton Common's
Treasures with the aim of putting the
whole collection on display for the
first time since their discovery in
1922 the treasures in these boxes will
shed new light on the story of Tuten
K thousands of objects were simply
packed away when they were first
Unearthed and have never been studied or
analyzed but now in the cuttingedge labs
and sto rooms of the grand Egyptian
museum all this is about to
change behind this unassuming door lies
an egyptologists Paradise wow welcome in
storage 93 especially for artifacts of
toan filled with Priceless treasures and
dripping with gold in this room tutan
Common's prized possessions are being
brought together to be stored and
conserved in climate controlled
conditions there's some boats staffs
there
beds Chris nonon is one of a tiny
handful of experts to gain
entry this is a super exciting moment to
be here to see all of this material
being ready for exhibition in in the new
Museum
it's once in a lifetime kind of chance
to see
this the last time these Treasures were
together was inside Tuton Common's
tomb
Professor Sela ikram believes it's only
Now by seeing the treasures together
that egyptologists can begin to tell the
full story of the pharaoh's life there
is so much material in the Tomb of tutan
it's really a bit like an attic where
you know people's mothers have put all
of their bits and pieces so that they
have their memories they have their
entire life encapsulated from babyhood
onwards and Tut's tomb is like opening
up his attic and being able to see
inside his past
life seen together ttin Common's
Treasures are now painting a radical new
portrait not the boy King as many had
thought this is totin common the warrior
king inside the tomb Howard Carter found
six
chariots seven throw
sticks four daggers dozens of bows
hundreds of arrows eight Shields and a
unique and sophisticated set of armor so
this wasn't just a hall of treasure it
was a veritable arsenal of weapons but
these weren't the toys of a boy King it
would seem they were the weapons of a
man people romantically called Tuton
khaman the boy King and that's because
he came to the throne when he was 9 and
a half but he died when he was about 19
and by the age of 14 in ancient Egypt a
man so really it's more of a romantic
myth calling him the boy King because he
really was a proper truly grown up
King today this King's Story is being
Rewritten by the artifacts he took to
the
afterlife and there's one treasure Tuton
common seems to have highly
valued tucked away in a corner of the
Cairo Museum lies a small dagger with a
big big
secret the latest technology has
revealed startling new information about
this weapon soon to be moved to the
Grand Egyptian
Museum
information that is out of this
world the sheer scale of Tuton common
Treasures is
breathtaking from gold Effigies to
elaborate beds to simple items of
clothing but Tuten common was also
buried with an arsenal of
weapons just draw after draw after draw
all containing
arrows this entire section yes just for
this one kind of object it's
amazing in this second Millennia BC
stockpile there's one weapon that Tuten
Commons seem to have highly
treasured since its Discovery this
spectacular dagger has been on display
in the Cairo
Museum tucked away in a corner passed by
as visitors flock to Tuton Common's Big
Ticket
Treasures might not be the most famous
object that was discovered in the Tomb
but I think this dagger is one of the
most interesting
this deadly weapon contains a secret
that's been hidden in plain sight for
nearly a
century now the dagger has been
reanalyzed to reveal Tuten common as a
warrior hungry for power in this world
and
Beyond the dagger was found inside tutin
Common's coffin it was resting directly
on his
body
this was one of the most important
objects for tutan Kon it seems it was
found very close uh to The Mummy just
above the king's
abdomen it's clear there was something
special about this dagger to Tuten
common and there's no doubt in its
beauty its handle is extremely finely
decorated in gold and these bands which
are inlaid with precious materials the
pommel at the end is made of rock
crystal this sheath made of beaten gold
is decorated with this very intricate
Floral
Pattern but tutan Common's tomb was
Dripping in Gold and Gems so why was
this dagger buried inside his coffin on
his
body what made it so precious the answer
lies in the dagger's blade perhaps the
most interesting aspect of it actually
is the blade which is made of iron iron
is one of the most common elements on
[Music]
Earth but in Tuten common Egypt iron was
rarer than
gold 3 and a half thousand years ago
iron was almost non-existent in Egypt we
don't get any archaeological evidence
for iron smelting in this part of the
world until the 6th Century
BC that's 800 years years after Tuten
common
died the iron in the dagger's blade
wasn't mined or smelted in Egypt so
where did it come
from the mystery has puzzled experts
since the dagger's discovery nearly a
century
ago but until recently there is no way
to know where the iron in the blade came
from without destroying it
now thanks to the use of advanced
non-destructive x-ray analysis curators
Can Shed new light on this ancient
mystery because there's more than iron
in this
blade this technique allows us to see
the kind of unique chemical fingerprint
of the blade of this
dagger and crucially it tells us the
percentage of the various different
elements iron occurs in nature mixed
with other elements this mixture is
unique to each source of the
metal by identifying the Blade's unique
chemical
fingerprint the curators have been able
to pinpoint its
origin so just we need everyone to move
away for 3 m 3 m please for health and
safety because we are now going to run
the
X-ray the machine fires high energy
x-rays into the dagger blade and it's
the energy reflected back that reveals
the elements contained
inside okay it's
done so what we have now is a result of
X-ray test and we can see the elements
here of the uh chemical composition and
we can see now Three Peaks which of the
iron and nickel and Cobalt
okay what the curators found was the
proportion of nickel was unusually high
what what does this tell us about the
kind of iron that was used to make this
dagger I mean this kind of chemical
composition is not find on the smelted
iron found in
Egypt or even in this
planet there's no match on Earth for the
iron in this
dagger if this iron doesn't come from
this planet where does it come from it's
only coming from the Mite from a
right
yes the iron in tutin Common's dagger is
extraterrestrial its Journey began
thousands perhaps millions of years
ago from the asteroid belt between Mars
and Jupiter 250 million miles away a
lump of rock and metal plummeting faster
than a bullet toward
Earth
it slammed into the planet's surface
shattering into fragments of molten
iron somewhere in the Sands of Africa
these fragments lay for thousands even
millions of years until they were found
and collected to be
melted forged and crafted into an object
of rare Beauty and Power
the iron in this dagger has been on an
extraordinary
Journey egyptologist Aiden Dodson
believes Tuten common knew this iron
fell from the
heavens back
1500 or 2,000 years earlier than tanam
Moon they talk about irons from the sky
as being a somewhat miraculous
material the iron has a power it's from
it's from the
gods to toot in common the dagger must
have seemed like a gift from the
[Music]
gods now another hidden set of artifacts
not seen in their original glory for 3
and a half thousand years are shedding
new light on Tuten Common's ambition a
unique combination of images that
display him as a powerful ruler of not
just Egypt but the
world duen common took six chariots to
the afterlife carefully dismantled and
stacked in his tomb's
antichamber when Howard Carter
discovered the tomb he found at least
1,500 tiny gold flakes Under The
Chariot he didn't have the technology to
deal with these bewildering metal
fragments so he put them in a box in the
hope that someone in the future might
now decades later these gold fragments
have been finally
reassembled world-renowned gold
conservator Dr Christian emman has been
piecing the flakes together his work
reveals a series of stunning images that
show totin at the center of the world
world so many tiny details are visible
again yeah which were not visible when
they were
excavated emman discovered these gold
fragments are parts of golden panels
once used as decorations on the
harnesses and trappings of totin
Common's
[Music]
chariots these bewildering fragile
jigsaw puzzles have so far Taken 3 years
to piece
together so every single piece which we
could reattach to the gold sheet is
another part of a huge puzzle but still
there are missing pieces and we try of
course now to fix those little things
yeah back to its original
position emman has pieced together at
least 70 intricately embossed gold
panels made to decorate six leather
Chariot
[Music]
harnesses and they would have made a
powerful impression on everyone who saw
them these images haven't been seen
since the doors were sealed on tutin
Common's tomb 3 and a half thousand
years
ago for egyptologist Professor Sala
ikron interpreting them is an incredible
[Music]
privilege this material is fabulous
because it's never been on display
before even though it is from the Tomb
of the most famous King Tuten
common Salma has been decoding these
images designs that reveal Tuten
Common's Ambitions stretched far beyond
Egypt's
borders the Tuten Chariot leather is
unusual because it doesn't just have
normal Egyptian propaganda imagery at
first glance you think oh this is just
sort of animals fighting amongst
themselves but then you realize there's
a griffin involved which is a near
Eastern animal some of the plants used
are very much in the Syrian tradition
and then you have this running spiral
which is a Gian so you've got this
cocktail of great Empires and great
artistic Traditions coming
together these foreign designs were
deliberately chosen to present toan as a
player on an international
stage and the most powerful ruler in the
ancient
world this combination of styles seems
to emphasize the fact that he wanted to
show that he had very long reaching arms
of power as it were and he could control
all sorts of places and
people the gold decorations from the
harnesses suggest Tuton common wanted to
be seen as an international
Statesman and a chariot about to be
moved to the Grand Egyptian museum shows
just how far he was prepared to go in
pursuit of that
power so this Chariot is going to be 3D
scanned today uh and so first thing that
has to happen of course is that this
case which has been protecting it for
decades is coming off right before our
eyes
here for egyptologist Chris nonon it's
an amazing opportunity to examine and
the chariot's lavishly decorated
surfaces before it's transported the
chariot's current condition must be
rigorously
analyzed so what's happening is that
this handheld device is being used and
to take a rapid succession a whole
sequence of images which are creating a
digital model of the Chariot and this is
incredibly important because we need to
understand the condition and the shape
um of The Chariot in its current
situation
so that it can then be reassessed when
it goes into the new Grand Egyptian
museum the detailed Digital model will
ensure the Chariot remains in exactly
the same condition after it's
moved one of the things that's just
incredible about being up this close
with these objects is you get a sense of
the incredibly fine
detail few people ever get beyond the
protective glass to study this
Chariot so it's a rare opportunity to
see just how the young Pharaoh wanted
the world to see
him what we can see here is some of this
utterly Exquisite decoration on the
inside of this Chariot it's um rendered
in beaten gold and it shows a freeze of
foreign captives enemies of tutan
Kain but this beautiful decoration
depicts graphic brutality that indicates
Tuten common would stop at nothing in
the pursuit of
power there's a rope which runs right
the way along this scene which is which
is binding them all some of them are
tied by the neck some of them have their
hands behind their backs some of them
have their hands tied at their wrists
and above their
heads their detailed features and
distinctive costumes identify the
captives as Egypt's traditional enemies
from the south and the north he was
trying to convey this idea of being the
ruler over all of the foreign people who
surrounded his
country armed with an iron Dagger from
the
gods and proclaiming his power from a
chariot decorated with golden images of
his International
Supremacy Tuten common set out to
dominate the ancient
world but these Treasures appear appear
to be too beautiful for the battlefield
so was all this just for show a king
playing it being a soldier or was it a
genuine warning that Tuten common was a
serious warrior
king now groundbreaking new Research
into a mysterious armored tunic found
inside Tuton Common's tomb could provide
the answer it was really a stateof Arts
piece of military
equipment this is the critical piece of
the puzzle that could prove just how far
Tuten common was prepared to go in
pursuit of
power and it raises the possibility that
Tuton common was willing to go to
[Music]
war in the state-of-the-art labs of the
grand Egyptian museum ancient leather
specialist Lucy Skinner has come to see
one of Tuton Common's most intriguing
Treasures this unique armored vest could
help prove something
extraordinary that Tuton common
dismissed for nearly a century as a
powerless boy King was willing to go to
war oh
wow these are the remains of Tuten
Common's personal armored
tunic it would have been an impressive
and intimidating
sight now 3 and a half thousand years
after it was in tuned with Tuten
common and after nearly a century in
storage it's been moved to the Grand
Egyptian
museum for Lucy it's her first
opportunity to analyze the armor up
close
it's fantastic to see it like this I've
been working with ancient Egyptian
leather for almost a decade and finally
I get to see this item actually that
piece can can you nothing like it has
ever been found from ancient
Egypt Lucy believes understanding how
the armor was made will shed new light
on why it was made and prove whether it
was made for show or for battle
at least 2,000 leather scales were
stitched together to
overlap ridges prevented the scales from
being forced
apart the result was flexible resilient
armor you can really see clearly can't
you how the the ridges on each of these
scales they overlapping each other if an
arrow were to hit the armor these ridges
prevent it somehow from coming apart so
it gives some added protection Lucy
believes a sophisticated manufacturing
technique made the armor strong and
flexible a practical piece of equipment
rather than a ceremonial
showpiece and to confirm her Theory Lucy
wants to examine two similar sized
scales in
detail so this technique is called
reflectance transformation Imaging it's
an Imaging process where you take a
series of photographs with different
lighting angles and then the shadows and
the highlights from each image are
Amalgamated into one and it just s of
highlights the details surface details
really really really clearly on the on
the surface of the
object so this is really excellent this
is great we can really see the texture
on the
surface it's the first time these scales
have ever been examined in forensic
detail and Lucy immediately notices a
striking similarity between the two
scales zoom in a little bit on
there
right these
scales they're almost exactly the same
aren't they in the same the same size um
the same width the kind of the The
Ridges are in exactly the same position
they're extremely consistent I mean it
really suggests that they they found the
optimal kind of method for making these
things and then they were reproducing it
again and again and
again to Lucy the best explanation for
the scale similarity is that they were
made using a
mold the medial Ridge you can really see
that it's very defined
I mean it strongly looks like it's been
pushed with some pressure into a
mold molding the leather would make the
scales consistent thick and strong Lucy
believes one reason to do that would be
to make tutan Common's armor battle
ready the way the surface looks super
compact like this it definitely um this
would deflect quite a large impact I
think ingenious ly designed and
meticulously
manufactured this armor was made to
withstand
arrows Lucy believes it wasn't for
show it was for battle and Tuten common
could have worn it on the
battlefield it was really a state-of
Arts piece of military equipment it was
almost like the Kevlar vest of the
ancient Egyptian
World a real Warrior facing real threat
would want such Advanced
armor but who was Tuten common planning
to go to war with who did he feel
threatened by and
why in the stor rooms of the new Grand
Egyptian museum egyptologist Professor
Salma ikram has found a bow belonging to
Tuten common that pictures his worst
enemies golly we've never seen this
before first time first time to see
it since its Discovery nearly a century
ago this bow has been locked away in the
basement of the old Cairo
Museum this is the top of the bow
because this has got the enemies of the
north and that's got the enemies of the
South the Nubians are in the South and
various asiatics are in the north and in
fact sometimes the libyans as well Salma
believes this bow was never never fired
in Anger it's too beautiful for the
battlefield but it's a critical clue in
Tuton common story because it reveals a
country and a pharaoh under
threat to the south insurgencies in the
colony of Nubia threatened Egypt's
supply of gold and precious goods from
Africa to the
Northwest Libyan tribes made violent
incursions into Egyptian
territory and in the East the aggressive
hittite Empire Advanced through Syria
ever closer to Egypt's
borders Egypt was been turmoil its
allies had become enemies and the
expansionist aggressive Hittites were
knocking on Egypt's
[Music]
[Applause]
door this is why Tuton com was buried
with an arsenal of
weapons as well as the celestial dagger
and high-tech armor curators at the
Grand Egyptian museum are unpacking
dozens of functional
bows hundreds of
arrows Shields and throw
sticks together they're painting a
picture of totin common as a warrior
king with the hardware and the
motivation to go to war
and this is forcing egyptologists to
look again at all of tutan Common's
Treasures even those that have been on
display in the old Cairo museum for
decades could Tuton Common's true
identity have been hidden in plain
sight was the warrior king in front of
us all
along so this is a box from the tomb of
ch
and it's decorated on all sides with
scenes of the king in his Chariot going
off after the
enemies and he's Waging War using the
exact same weapons that egyptologists
and scientists are analyzing at the
Grand Egyptian
museum the large
bow
arrows and armored
tunic the decorated harness and
chariot
have the king Shan riding his Chariot
and he draws this massive bow and lets
fly and all of the enemies from the
south are then being hit by his arrows
and are falling down at his
feet and what's nice then
is on the other side you have a very
similar thing happening but this is for
the northern enemy of Egypt so they're
you know they're big bearded people from
Syria area and and they're being
trampled by the king's horses they're
Ping On to go under the wheels of the
Chariots um and again to muham is
loosening his bow and off they
go this is Tuton common the warrior king
in the thick of battle leading from the
front you got a sense of the landscape
and the chaos and the Heat
it's
fantastic since its Discovery nearly a
century ago the images on this box have
been dismissed as fantasy but the
weapons pictured on the box are the same
as the weapons found in Tuten Common's
tomb so if the weapons shown here were
real were these events real
too are these violent battle scenes
closer to reality
than some have previously thought did
tutan common lead Egypt's armies into
battle the answer lies outside the grand
Egyptian
museum on the banks of the Nile and
thieves in the spectacular ruins of
Luxor
Temple
this was ancient Egypt's religious
capital and every Pharaoh wanted to make
their Mark here by Recycling and
recarving stones from earlier
buildings we don't have a lot of
evidence for tutan kon's buildings but
we do have fragments here and there that
suggest that he might have erected
temples and that if he did he would have
included battle scenes like
this today Tuton Common's battle
carvings are scattered across the site
pieces of a colossal seemingly
impossible three-dimensional jigsaw
puzzle archaeologist Ray Johnson has
spent 20 years painstakingly recording
and digitally reassembling tutin
Common's battle
scenes with fascinating
results the chillingly Vivid details
include severed hands skewered on sticks
and a prisoner hanging from a ship's
mast egyptologist Aiden Dodson believes
these carvings are more than simply
propaganda as many have
thought the nature of these reliefs is
such that they don't appear to be
stereotyped ones they seem to be
specific and therefore I think there's a
reasonable case to could be made that
these blocks from lsaw do report a
particular
campaign
and in this campaign totin common takes
Center Stage it seems likely that the
king had some direct involvement
physically in these campaigns and
there's no reason to assume that the
king if he's being shown there wasn't
actually
there some egyptologists now believe
these shattered fragments of stone
record real historical events and that
the image of Tuton common as a frail boy
King has to be reassessed he wouldn't be
in that case a kind of feeble diseased
guy who had trouble walking couldn't
possibly have participated any in any
sort of athletic events instead we'd be
looking at a kind of a young vigorous
athletic
Warrior the celestial dagger and
decorated Chariot reveal a man hungry
for
power the arsenal of weapons and
high-tech armor suggest he was ready to
fight and the painted box and carved
battle scenes are powerful evidence that
Tuten common LED his armies into
battle together these Treasures suggest
a different image of the world's most
famous
Pharaoh as a warrior king who may have
gone to war and possibly never
returned
[Music]
in the labs of the new Grand Egyptian
museum history is being
re-examined and a picture of Tuten
common as a warrior king has
emerged a man hungry for
power protected by high-tech
armor and a magical iron Dagger from the
gods leading from the front In the Heat
of battle a man who died at age
[Applause]
19 did the Young Pharaoh die in
battle did tutan common make the
ultimate
[Music]
sacrifice in the Valley of the Kings
inside the tomb where he was laid to
rest 3 and a half thousand years ago
lies the mummified body of to in common
for 33 centuries oils and resins have
preserved his body and his secrets for
the last century since his tomb's
Discovery debate has raged over his
cause of death there has been endless
speculation about whether he had malaria
whether he had septicemia which killed
him whether he'd been hit on the head so
really a lot of ink has been spilt on
this instead Selma believes the key to
discovering what killed tutin common
isn't to investigate how he died but
where and she thinks this x-ray of Tuten
common skull contains a
clue here's a skull and this is a layer
of resin and this is a second layer of
resin so the fact that they're two
different layers of resin suggest that
Tuten Haron was mummified in uh two part
art sort of process which is very
unusual mummification needed to begin
within days of
death immediately what you have to do is
void the body of its internal organs and
sometimes even the brain because
otherwise you get bacteria and you puff
up and you might explode the two-part
process may be a sign the tutan common
was mummified temporarily to prevent
decomposition before a full mum
ification could take place it is
possible that he died away from the Nile
Valley and so some form of initial
mumification was carried out it could be
because he was on an expedition of some
sort now it could be that he was
fighting some sort of campaign in the
desert not close to the
Nile a chest x-ray reveals something
even
stranger there's something very obvious
missing because there's no heart and the
Egyptians always kept the heart in the
body because you have to keep the heart
in order to make a safe transition
between this world and the next the
absence of the heart might suggest that
whoever carried out the mummification
was not as skilled as they should have
been or that Tuten needed immediately
attention somewhere far from where the
top class imas
were the evidence suggests duon common
could have died far from home
around late 1323 BC Egypt armies were
750 mi from home in Northern Syria
fighting their Arch enemies the
Hittites if Tuten common was the warrior
king that the evidence
suggests then chances are he could have
been there
too we know that Egypt was involved in
military activities in Northern Syria
whether or not damoon was at the head of
the armies right in the in the depths of
Syria one can probably argue the idea
that he had actually was up there in
Syria with the Egyptian armies seems
pretty
persuasive it's possible totin common
fought and died in this campaign in a
distant corner of Egypt's
Empire cut down in the prime of his life
as a warrior
king
well perhaps tan Kon died just as he was
leaving his Mark he' begun to regain
territory overseas which had been lost
to reestablish Egypt as the great power
in the region and you know who knows if
he'd lived perhaps he would have had a
great and glorious Reign and his dynasty
would have carried on for a long time
and history would have been very
different
as the thousands of tutan common
Treasures are reunited at the new Grand
Egyptian
museum many paint a picture of a young
Pharaoh determined to stamp Egypt's mark
on the world a Celestial knife one of
his most personal and prized possessions
newly restored gold Chariot decorations
depicting an international Statesman and
cuttingedge body armor suggesting he was
ready to go into battle for his country
together they tell the story of Tuten
common as a warrior not a boy but a man
who may have made the ultimate
[Music]
sacrifice